First of
all, let's stop with someone else If this guy sleeps, he'll fight three times Wasser
How many times will
Kart do
it?  Don't let me wash it away
Management is a dangerous weapon Lizard Snake After all, it seems we have it Let's close the
cherry blossoms already Well, let's see how it goes Well then
, the first round of the crown game
I'm the only spoon walker
You guys, Shirai Sugai, who did this week, please
Please do it seriously Are
you fooling around?
Applause]
How many times that weapon haha
[music]
[applause]
3 wh
[music]
power decided before
[laughter]
Lizard seems to be ishinema
goo
toranoana
[applause]
come on papa
t 2
sounds
I still have a lot of things I'm still doing ah I still
have it I just need
to
get luxury
Ichigo still  Please
protect me Kao is over